[Music]
it's been a weird time in the months
leading up to the release of avengers 4.
when fans haven't been sobbing over the
events of avengers infinity war they've
been crafting intricate theories about
how the surviving crew might find a way
to reverse thanos universe decimating
snap
and bring our fallen marvel favorites
back to life though it's a lovely
thought that the turn to dust gang will
return
it may not actually come to fruition
according to scarlet witch actress
elizabeth olsen
things aren't going to get better in
avengers 4 speaking at ace comic-con in
chicago
olson offered a blunt warning about the
future of the earth's mightiest heroes
it's only going to get worse loki actor
tom hiddleston joined olson on stage for
the convention panel during which he
noted that both his character
and olsen scarlet witch had to make the
ultimate sacrifice in infinity war
trading a life for the greater good
speaking to olson he said
the thing you have to do at the end of
infinity war is a kind of sacrifice
and arguably loki makes a similar one as
fans will recall loki died in the very
first scene of the film after trying to
trick thanos
[Music]
no resurrections this time scarlet
witch's sacrifice came at the end when
she had to kill vision in order to
extract the mind stone from his forehead
and destroy it
to make matters even more devastating
scarlet witch didn't even survive
infinity war
after killing her true love and then
seeing him die a second time
she floated away into space dust
completely erased from reality
the upside to olson's grim comments here
is that both she
and hiddleston will appear in avengers 4
in some capacity
despite biting the dust in infinity war
insiders previously spotted olsen in
atlanta georgia filming reshoots for
avengers 4.
the actress herself also shared a
sense-deleted post to her instagram
story that revealed a bruise she got
while shooting the film
olson wrote in the caption of the photo
that the bruise came about while scarlet
witch quote
took flight which suggests that her
character will be alive and well enough
to take to the skies for some epic
action sequences in the fourth avengers
flick
as for hiddleston he isn't 100 confirmed
for avengers 4 but set photos have shown
him filming what looks to be a flashback
or time travel sequence for the film
surprise it's hard to imagine that after
all the pain the avengers and company
suffered an
infinity war things are going to get
even bleaker but
might the intense doom and gloom only
last a short while before the heroes
taste
sweet success
fan theories have it that avengers 4
will feature time travel with the
surviving heroes banding together taking
a journey through the quantum realm
and visiting the past to defeat thanos
before he can collect the infinity
stones
leaked promotional art for avengers 4
shows thor captain america
and rocket raccoon wearing silver white
red and black suits
ones that look similar to the costume
hank pym wore when he was searching for
janet van dyne in the quantum realm
many have taken this as proof that
earth's mightiest heroes will visit the
past in avengers 4
and will utilize the quantum realm to
get there additional pieces of evidence
that support the time travel
theory are the photos of captain america
ant-man hulk and iron man on the
avengers 4 set
filming a scene that looks a lot like
the battle of new york from 2012's
avengers
we've also seen leaked concept art that
depicts captain america and what looks
like his suit
from captain america civil war and black
widow rocking red hair
the same shade she wore in the avengers
and its sequels rather than the blonde
bob she sported an infinity war
all this considered it seems highly
likely that avengers 4 will start off
super
dark before it turns back the clock and
takes a trip to the big apple for thanos
vs avengers showdown
round two with little luck and a whole
lot of butt kicking maybe the heroes
truly will be able to defeat thanos and
revive their fellow vigilantes so that
everyone can live happily ever after
avengers 4 is set for release on may 3rd
2019